I'm going to give you that jetpack bud
you know the moment I touch a jetpack
I'm going to put it on and fly off into
space kill myself and lose the jet pack
all in one call SPO God I hope so if you
hear a kaboom it went poorly goodbye
everybody goodbye You're Not Safe you're
very much not he
dead oh yeah he's
dead I
very well let's turn it in we're
swimming in it that's enough for a
jetpack oh get it get it get it get it
for it you wanted it you got it all
right go go go almost almost took oh oh
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh right
my an good that very not good oh yeah oh
oh man what happened battery powered
fuel
Bob
B what did me the g to g b no oh God oh
God oh what was
that did you get did you get his
walkie-talkie
I got it do you want to try this out I
don't think I do no actually I all right
um what do I do charge it left click
probably E I don't know something all
right
okay it says left Mouse button but it's
not working no it's like is it out of is
it charge is not of fuel I don't know I
I hit it on the I don't know if it's
this though does it have separate fuel
that you got to buy not that I know of
because it blew up did it is it dead I
don't I don't know man I don't know the
jetpack I don't I don't I've not messed
with it it's probably fine let's uh
let's um uh I don't see fuel n Bob will
he'll sleep it off and and all will be
well yeah yeah we'll just um we'll just
go up yeah let's just go
up hey man oh what a good nap hey oh
good yeah uh so malware broadcaster
makes it so that when we disable mines
or turrets instead of disabling they
blow up oh
means they're permanently gone however
there's an explosion radius so you can't
be too close to them when they blow up
oh that's okay yeah I don't know what
happened to it that might be busted I
think it it went pretty well for a first
try honestly I didn't yeah I think that
was Minecraft world one more time before
we probably disable it
forever yeah oh I didn't even notice the
tower why is there a
tower uh don't know but do you want to
know a secret
sure I believe there's a fire exit
entrance right over here too
ah you don't
say well maybe it's random cuz this is
not the same as I
remember what are the never mind I stand
corrected I don't see a fire exit here
okay I'm going go
in yeah same I forgot to charge my
walkie so this might be shortlived I I
do think I broke the uh jetpack
unfortunately that's okay it only it it
was Pennies on the dollar to replace
it I'm coming in
too all right ooh
Diamond
nice wow a map that's not a
dungeon
Apple
oh so many good
things this place is
loaded yeah already full up I just
walked in why is it
loaded I guess that's just the way the
wife is in Minecraft that you can go all
the way into that literally has nothing
in that's unfortunate there's a lot of
goodies in here though of
goodies
holy
[__] all right I'm going to go grab a
key oh is that a key never mind yep I'm
going to use
that
after that better be you Wade that
better be
you man there's so much you can explore
and nothing nothing nothing at
all oh I found a what might be a fire
exit but probably
isn't oh
God oh
God what is
that hello someone
there okay it's a bug it's a bug it's
just a bug get back to you on
that all right it's just a
bug get out of here
bug yeah yeah
I found a big ass Diamond like a whole
block I'm going to go back to the ship
with this stuff yeah how valuable is
that it looks very valuable I don't know
probably I didn't even look at its
value Bob we got so much stuff outside
the
entrance oh me too me too and yeah oh
hey hey watch out above you there's a
bird he's fine okay
damn
134 man this Minecraft place is kind of
Rich this more so if we run into the
thumper at the same time hey man hi what
what hey just say
hi you guys headed back in oh I see
there are good goodies upstairs
there I know you're dealing with
something and I'm very proud of you but
just wanted you to know we're good we're
good yeah basically the way that those
bugs are guarding kind of there is
something around the corner there's two
somethings around the corner Bob there's
something around the corner to you
around that land mine let me blow up
that land mine Don't Go Near that
again okay that land mine has been taken
care of let me blow up
D6
whoa careful Bob uh don't back into that
corner there's a land mine right across
that door right on the other side lots
of goodies where you are though
everywhere where you are there's like
five
goodies yeah wait you got like five in
the immediate
area
yeah they're all in there all the
goodies oh oh God
uhoh all right Mark I need help us get
the last bit of stuff that was outside
okay ship seems to be clear right now so
we could probably make when does it
leave midnight
correct there's time for one more run
all right I'm going for it
okay we're going to be Filthy
Rich can you get everything Mark or do
you need help nope got it
all there he
is all right just made it that's
everything that was literally everything
loaded dude Minecraft world God
damn killed like four or five things in
there too he was murdering we killed we
killed a couple Thumpers I killed like
four loot bugs I killed spider CRA holy
crap oh you killed the spider too yeah
it was kind of stuck in a corner so I it
didn't really fight back but I did hey
you know what we take the wins more of a
mercy kill but still counts sustain the
most injuries well all right okay all
right great a wow
damn well holy [__] we got two days left
to do this good God we could we could
absolutely screw up so bad right now
let's go get white boys all right what
move you want I mean we can do Minecraft
again let's do it we can't afford any of
the paid ones good let's just do let's
get some money let's get some money yeah
let's do mcraft can I be big daddy in
the boat and uh and guide you Fellers so
cuz you know I'm going to get killed if
I keep pushing my luck here it's best to
have someone here to go home if there is
something that terrible that happens CU
we don't want to lose this when you both
die I'll just pull the lever and get the
hell out of yeah don't even try a lot of
turrets in there's a lot of turrets in
mines I should just like do yeah no if
there's a lot of turrets in mines I
should just like spam spam disable them
all the time right yep yes but not when
we're close to any of them got it all
right get us to mcraft I'm ready no
that's not
Minecraft oh weather foul I don't want
to take any risks
just want to risk anything right all
right whatever yeah well the big money's
in Minecraft you got big daddy in the
boat okay all right okay okay all right
okay all right I'm going to see if the
back entrance is good probably not oh
that's not wait where am
I I'm looking for a present see a
present Mark what Mark I found an
abandoned nest what do you mean just
don't go down toward the fire exit block
which definitely means this is going to
be the castle oh
good oh boy oh
[Music]
gift oh
goo we got goo over
here oh yeah you do can you kill
goo no you can't kill I did not believe
so you got a couple loots in that big
room you're in
Mark really I'm not seeing it there's
one to your right like right next to you
uh left stop turning it's between you
and the door right now almost a little
bit to the left the door you
okay I see nothing right there right
there right there what's that what uh
nothing I don't know okay you just
walked over so if you don't see it must
be in another level or something oh oh
got it got
[Music]
it and then there's two more loot
further into the room one on the left
wall one on the right wall from the
entrance you came
in yeah my radar my scanner is not
working I don't know why right here yeah
my scanner's not picking up anything but
there definitely was a remote on the
floor oh no that's not it I don't see
anything here
either yeah Wade's got nothing
either well you're not Waits on
one and then the way that Waits looking
there's another one that on that wall
right in front of
you found
leave yeah yeah yeah all right that's a
dead end room with nothing else in it
you have a shovel yeah I got a shovel
why there's a loot blood guarding a key
all right I'll I'll kill him one second
let me drop this stuff outside one
second all right let me wall up this guy
he's like all the way down the staircase
like I don't know if it's might be
guarding L but I'll get
him turn just chilling back
there what the freak was
that there or an enemy or
something oh yeah what's
that got him he he's dead this to be a
dead end otherwise nothing good there
yeah we just took a key from a l and
murdered him I did hear a voice stick I
just want to mention I did hear a voice
uh if you go around to your left I see
some loot uh W left yeah and then Mark
if you go down the next right
uh-huh yeah some on the floor there yep
got
that a Stairway at the end of that hall
and then you're going into a new room
but not seeing Loot on your area
okay I'm going to poke my head
downstairs you tell me if I see
[Music]
anything uh yeah to your left M uh yeah
if you go left and then right down the
hall left and then right there should be
some loot in one of the jail cells oh
other way
sorry
aha someone need cup
noodle I need a
gift okay I oops I oh God oh God oh God
oh God I don't like that doing weird
stuff uh there was something down there
skittering I would not open that door on
the radar but that doesn't really mean
anything it was a lot of skitters a lot
of talking we're not hearing
anything no I wasn't talking to the walk
I'm just talking to
Mark oh Mark that's a spider oh okay I
thought it was uh here you want stop
sign Red
Dot here here stop sign thanks all right
let's get him I won't hit you I
swear oh oh you got it apparently
W hang on I got it I got it oh critical
injury is it dead no it's
not got it oh oh God
help okay it's not
dead oh got it okay well that didn't go
well all right that didn't go well
Wade's dead but the spider
not going better I'm going to be
honest I'm hearing things I'm going to
start I'm going to bail uh help I'm
going to bail yeah y I don't know where
the exit is so I'll help you I'm he in
many
voices there might be dogs outside if
you do make it outside
careful to your left Mark uh no no no go
ahead left no no no what stop turning
back is he coming
up oh my goodness that was
terrifying okay there's some things
outside the entrance but how bad does it
look over
you oh it's bad oh it's bad oh it's bad
oh it's bad oh it's
bad oh it's bad okay
juked I think it's because
like
bail bail bail bail bail bail bail we're
leaving time to go oh my God
okay bye triple uh yes
bye oh what the freak was it what did
you
do let's just organize stuff is it all
the villagers got some apples and
everything everybody's waiting in line
for their turn oh good that's good know
normal normal stuff totally same
behavior oh
hey yeah that we almost had him really
did not do very well with that spider I
got to be honest it was really bad place
to engage on the stairs where it could
reach us and we couldn't reach it yeah
yeah but then it got stuck and I could
reach it and it couldn't reach turns out
The High Ground was not the thing that
you wanted which you know I would never
have guessed well Minecraft world stormy
ah who
cares you want to go there with it
stormy yeah whatever ever with nothing
metal in there
right sure yes probably oh you're right
you should definitely still have someone
on the ship doing ship things so yeah
yeah
definitely oh it's it's
fine I feel
safe I am
safe holy crap oh good I need to get
Minecraft
B
why is it raining in here oh uh it's
raining inside oh
B found the fuse box but I think
everything's on already yeah I think
leave
it man weird weather huh
hey Waits wait in the um wait inside
with
us what what does that
mean like wait is right next to me so no
one's on the boat so we could die and
lose everything that we've worked for
well that's unlikely
though
I found the fuse box Mark I
see yeah this place is a little
Labyrinthian all right wait to leave it
he's got inventory full of stuff there
is a thumper and a for lizard
um if I hit a fire exit and it doesn't
do anything is that mean it's
okay yeah that's fine I think I'm going
to die
Mark oh oh I made I made it out I'm fine
I'm fine there might be a thumper in the
main lobby all right if Wade's next to
you can you ask him about the fire exit
thing I'm pretty sure it's
fine all right well oh God no not today
oh
no here's W made it back who who oh one
of you you [__] did my
be I don't
know I took his
th no well now you're just not listening
you took my
be [__] what's wrong with your voice
wait hey what's wrong with your voice
look I found the back way in so you shut
up and go away I don't need
you I've lost the back
way interesting what where I don't know
I don't know what happened it was here I
thought
nope
interesting Mark I it was right here I
don't know what happened to
it Mark
what oh oh it's right over here no it's
not where did it go
whoa I swear it was right here but it's
not anymore I don't know how I lost it
but I
did oh ow oh ow oh ow oh ow oh my God oh
my
f
B who's chasing
you yeah I also think there's a fake
Mark running around what the real Mark
he's saying he saying your voice he's
doing your
voice that's a fake that's a fake Mark
oh should we get out of
here oh
hey I'd pull that lever all right well
that's unfortunate for Mark glad I knew
he was dead and I carried his
back those
bees yeah
they you stole my bee you stole my bonus
and then I had to die to
bees you plotted My Demise I did plant a
lucrative beehive in your path thinking
maybe that that would get you killed you
bastard you took my assignment even
though I said at the very beginning and
then you were all silent no radio talk
for Wade no radio talking isn't that
suspicious Bob isn't that
suspicious isn't that suspicious isn't
that suspicious wasn't talking on the
radio at all not at all all come here
come here Nar a peep yes look
H I was just sexually harassed
by the best in the
best I am not the one with whom to bring
this up boy shall we make
money we shall all the
money yep
uh-oh Mar I thought you
died I hear uhoh and then I thought I
thought I might have get might get
pancaked by the ship but uh I was okay
thankfully
open open
shoping open
shoping cell oh
[Music]
God your hand workk is invaluable to the
company
comp who wa my God interesting
that
it that's it guys we're going to be so
freaking rich we're going to be so rich
so are you guys ready to be freaking
loaded right now we're going to have
some cash
money all
money how much money we got
1574 we oh my we currently have 1729 in
the old bank account and we haven't
gotten our bonus
yet he we got our opponents well done
boys this is how we do it even though I
died embarrassingly and I couldn't
remember where the fire exit was somehow
I carried us through no one other than
me gets to feel embarrassed about what
just happened at this session it's oh my
[__] godamn it I got uh blindsided by
uh coil killed by a spider I don't
remember the other
ones I didn't die at all that' be a fun
edit good
luck lixian make it so I didn't die at
all here actually what I'll do LIC just
take this and make a super compilation
of all my deaths but I'm going to go oh
man that was close oh I made
it woo success and
living oh man that was too fun oh glad
to be alive and then just yeah make it
so I
lived you can do that right it's cute
that you think that's in all the voice
lines you'll
need make it actually no make my way my
deaths Wade's deaths go find some some a
compilation of Wade screaming and then
replace his With Me Mine with
his interpret that as you will cuz I
don't know what the [__] you just asked
[Music]
for